Dr. Bailey is a professor of psychology
at Northwestern University and highly
regarded for his work on the
etiology of sexual orientation,
gender nonconformity,
the genetics of sexual orientation
and the sexual arousal response.
He's the author of the well known book,
the man who would be queen the science
of gender bending and transsexualism,
which was published in 2003 and his work
has received widespread attention in
the media, including the Boston
Globe and Washington Post, CBS,
CBS news just to name a few.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview with Dr. Michael Bailey.
So welcome Mike.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for having me.
So one of the questions I
wanted to ask you about, um,
so you start off our conversation today
is what got you interested in studying
emotion and sex, sort of, where did
it all begin in the first place?
Well, uh, I was, uh,
clinical psychology graduate student at
the University of Texas and I was taking
a graduate,
uh,
sex course and it became clear to
me how much interesting questions,
how many, how much interesting
work there was to be done, uh,
in that domain. Uh, you
know, let's be honest,
everybody finds sex to be
a pretty interesting topic,
but for various reasons,
people tend to avoid it.
And it seemed like an each,
uh,
that and you know, I really glad
that I went there because I've, uh,
been able to do some interesting things.
Fantastic.
And so some of the interesting things
you've been doing or exactly where I'd
like to Kinda start off our
questions today about your work,
because it's something like you're saying,
that appeals to almost
everyone yet I'm really,
I think until use pioneer work in
this area, we knew almost nothing,
especially when we related it to things
like sexual arousal and emotion. Um,
so what I'd love to ask you a bit
about, so in this realm, I mean,
you're really widely known
for demonstrating distinct
patterns of sexual arousal
response between men and women.
And men and women of differing
kind of sexual orientations.
So I wonder if you might say a little bit
about what you saw as some of the most
exciting discoveries when you first
embarked in this line of research?
Sure. So, uh, we've known
for awhile that men,
uh,
there's a close at that start over.
Uh, we've known for
awhile that in men, uh,
there is a close correspondence between
their sexual orientation and their
pattern of sexual arousal
in the laboratory. That is,
for example, a homosexual
men. Uh, we'll get,
uh,
erections to stimulate depicting men,
uh, but not so much to
stimulate depicting women.
A heterosexual men show
the opposite. Uh, in fact,
I think that, uh, for men, uh,
sexual orientation is a
pattern of sexual arousal.
That's how we know what our
sexual orientation is. Um,
we really haven't known
much about women for Awhile,
uh, in part because how to
measure sexual arousal in women,
uh, was less clear. Um,
and men you can measure,
uh, the degree of erection. You know,
that's a pretty obvious way to do
it. And women, what do you measure?
Well, Eh, uh,
people have constructed an instrument
that seems to work pretty well. Uh,
it measures,
uh,
blood flow and the vagina and
in both men and women. Uh,
genital arousal depends upon the
flow of blood and the genitals.
Um, so anyway, uh,
we were interested in
whether in women as well. Uh,
sexual orientation corresponds
with a pattern of sexual arousal.
Uh, and so we did the analogous
study. And by the way,
in our studies we showed videos of
couples having a pretty graphic sex.
Uh, and the, uh,
most interesting kinds of couples are
same sex couples that is either two men or
two women. Uh, people
who like men should, uh,
respond to the stimulate with two women,
people who like men,
should I respond to the
stimulate depicting men.
So we did this study with, uh, both
heterosexual and homosexual women,
and we found, uh, that
heterosexual women, uh,
really respond, uh, to both equally,
uh,
very different than either
heterosexual or homosexual women.
Men, uh, who show a strong bias. They,
their preferred sex.
It will a heterosexual women show a
bisexual arousal pattern in the lab.
That's not to say that they are bisexual,
it's just to say that their
sexual arousal pattern,
their genital sexual arousal patterns
provide no information regarding their
sexual preference or sex with men.
Sex with women,
lesbians, uh, showed a somewhat
biased arousal pattern.
They got slightly more
sexually aroused, uh, to,
uh, female stimulated than
to mail stimulate. Uh,
but it was not nearly as
strong a bias as men show. Hmm.
So what do you think this tells us about,
you know,
you've spoken a bit about this already,
but to the relative influence of,
you know, gender on the one hand and
sexual orientation on the other end,
really kind of predicting
our degree of sexual arousal?
Well,
I think that the clearest thing that
shows us is that men and women do sexual
orientation differently. Uh, and, uh, men,
I think we understand pretty well. Uh, and
I'll just repeat. I think that for men,
sexual orientation is precisely
a pattern of sexual arousal.
It's their emotional response to a
attractive men versus attractive women.
That's not what sexual orientation
has for women. In fact,
I think that we barely understand
sexual orientation and women,
there's a lot of work to do,
but it's not about sexual arousal
at least as far as we can tell.
So it's really interesting and
I mean, you've really, you know,
pioneered other research related to sexual
orientation that I want to ask you a
bit more about as well.
I mean,
one of the lines in particular is on
gender nonconformity and you know, what,
that your work seems to really
interestingly support some of the common
stereotypes that we may have
for gay men and lesbian women.
And I wonder if you could say a
bit more about these findings.
Well, okay. Um, first of all,
we've known for quite a long time that,
uh,
childhood gender nonconformity is
associated with adult homosexuality.
That is a boys who are,
uh, relatively feminine.
You have a better chance than
boys who are typical, uh,
in their gender role behavior,
uh, to become gay man. And a,
an analogous, uh, uh, relation holds for,
uh, women. Um,
we know this both on retrospective
studies and prospective studies,
uh, and there are clearly
stereotypes about the way that,
uh, for example, gay men, uh,
move and speak and what their
interests are and so on.
And there are also stereotypes
about lesbians. Uh,
are these stereotypes true?
Well,
it was a very fashionable in the
seventies and eighties and into the 90s,
uh, to say, well, of course not.
There are no differences
between heterosexual and
homosexual people except who
they want to have sex with.
Um,
but we have started to study
these phenomena in the lab.
Uh,
we've actually gotten pretty
far and there's no longer
any doubt that on average
the stereotypes are true. Uh, we,
if we videotape a homosexual and
heterosexual men, for example,
people are much better than
chance at, uh, telling who's who,
even though the men don't
mention their sexuality at all.
Uh, now I should emphasize that,
uh, people aren't perfect at it.
Uh,
these phenomena are true on average,
which is the only way that
stereotypes are ever true. Um,
and I'll also say that, um, there's
nothing wrong with these stereotypes,
in my opinion,
that a gay men are somewhat feminine,
does not mean to me that
they're inferior in any way.
Uh, I think many straight men could
stand to be a bit more feminine. Uh,
stereotypes in the gender realm tend to
be a true on average and this is one of
the [inaudible].
And so it's interesting to,
I mean,
you've also looked at how behavioral
genetics right can also inform our
understanding of sexual
orientation. And I wonder, you know,
to what extent your work and
work of others you've read
does suggest that sexual
orientation can be influenced to
some degree by genetic factors.
The genetics of sexual orientation is
something that I've been interested in
ever since I entered sex research.
It's one of the things I studied in my
dissertation and I had done several twin
studies of, uh, sexual orientation.
My views on what the data say
have evolved somewhat. Uh,
the early studies seem to
show a very strong, uh,
influence of genes on sexual orientation.
Uh,
those studies. However, um, we're
not the best studies in terms of,
um, the way that, uh,
participants were sampled.
Uh, since I did most of those
studies, I can criticize them as,
uh, and uh, as, uh,
sampling has gotten better with the
use of twin registries. And so on.
Uh, the, uh, concordance rates,
that is the degree of similarity
between twins have the same pair,
have shrunken, uh, and, uh,
estimates of genetic causation
have shrunk and somewhat to, uh,
I would say that it still looks
like genes play a role, but, uh,
less of a role then for, um, most
other traits that have been studied.
Uh, that makes sense to me. Uh,
given the evolutionary paradox
of how genes for homosexuality,
uh, might persist, you know,
a homosexual people, uh,
uh,
seem not to be as interested in mating
with the opposite sex and reproducing a
as heterosexual people.
And so we would expect genes
for homosexuality to, uh,
uh, be disadvantaged evolutionarily.
And, uh, I think that the,
uh, genetic data, the best genetic
data are consistent with that.
So,
I mean finally,
this has been really interesting talking
with you about your work on, you know,
sexual arousal, sexual orientation, and
even the role potentially have, you know,
behavioral genetics and
helping us understand to
what extent genes play a role
in these kinds of sexual, you
know, preferences and behaviors.
And so I think one thing that's really
important in all of this is that,
you know, your work has used these really
precise methodological tools to study.
You know,
as you said at the outset,
this is one of the most fundamental
domains of what makes us human.
And it's such a central part of, you know,
motivational systems at the same time,
it's been largely taboo for,
for various reasons.
And so I think part of what's great to
talk with you is also to hear about your
expertise and sort of what you see as
the most innovative tools or stimulating
or ways that researchers can try to study,
you know,
sex and sexual arousal better.
Given that it is a domain that seems not
to be as largely tapped into as others.
So I just wonder if you might
say a little bit more about this,
where people who are less
familiar with this kind of work?
Well,
I do think that
studying sexual arousal is very
important for people who want to study,
uh, sexual orientation, uh, in part, uh,
you know,
otherwise we're reliant on
people's self reports and,
uh, that can be misleading,
uh, particularly, uh,
when some sexual orientations or
stigmatized as homosexuality has been,
although it is decreasingly stigmatized,
obviously.
Uh, so, uh,
and also people don't always have
perfect insight into what their sexual
feelings are.
Uh,
so I do think it is important to
try to use objective measures and,
uh, genital sexual arousal
is an objective measure. Uh,
it does have some problems in that.
Um,
people don't always,
men especially don't always respond
enough to give a good signal.
A one innovation that we've
been trying is to, uh,
move the action upstairs
to studying the brain, uh,
using brain imaging. Uh, Fmr. I, uh,
we've done a fairly large study by FMRP
standards on men and we're completing
one on women. And, uh,
my preliminary results I
would say are that, uh,
well I'm a little disappointed.
Uh, I would have thought that Fmr,
I would have had an advantage,
uh,
over genital measures
because, um, you know,
sexual feelings start in
the brain and, uh, you know,
one can have the feeling of sexual arousal
without an obvious genital response.
Uh, nevertheless, I think that, um,
our results suggest that a brain imaging
as it stands today in 2012 is not as
sensitive and measured
as the genital measures.
So what do you see then as some of the
challenges in conducting this kind of
work?
Well, I think, uh, the
biggest challenge remains, uh,
people's squeamishness,
uh,
regarding matters of sex. And that, um,
starts with, for example,
a potential participants.
It also affects Irb,
institutional review boards and
their scrutiny that they give, uh,
research. And, uh,
perhaps most importantly,
funding agencies. Uh, and, uh,
people who hire for jobs at universities,
uh,
are all hesitant to,
favor of sex research or they,
they're all prejudiced
against sex research actually.
So I think that
we need to work on having people
accept that sexuality is an important,
uh,
part of human life and as deserving
of attention as any other emotion.
So then as you think about the future of,
you know,
research and emotion and how it can try
to include measures of sexual arousal
and sexuality more broadly,
where might you see the future of the
field headed in a way that can begin to
really, you know, except you know,
and expand this line of work on,
like you're saying,
an important part of what makes us
human important part of everyday life?
Well, I think that, um,
I think that one direction will depend
upon, uh, breakthroughs in the field,
which is simply, uh, you know,
the instruments to measure sexual arousal.
We have to keep trying to develop better
instruments, things that are less, uh,
intrusive, uh, you know, for example,
a genital measures,
you know,
have to go on the genitals and
the lab and, and people are, uh,
uh,
hesitant to do that.
So we need to develop a better
instruments or at least less invasive
instruments.
Uh,
and we just need to keep educating
people about our findings.
Uh,
and hopefully there'll be
interested enough in the findings,
uh,
to want more.
So finally, I want to ask, you know,
related to the future of the field,
a big part of this are the next generation
of students that are going to be
pushing this kind of research forward.
So when students come to you and they're
interested in sort of embarking in a
study of sexual arousal
or sexual orientation,
what kind of advice do you usually
give them or would you give them?
Well, I, I, I would say it's a
fine thing to be interested in.
It's important I'd be aware
of the barriers in this,
uh, field research, uh, the
attitudes that people have.
Uh, the, the fact that, uh,
finding this hard to get
that jobs are relatively few,
uh, and trying to change
that. If you can't. Hmm.
Well, thank you very much. Um, it was
a pleasure speaking with you today.
Thank you.
And with that,
this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Dr. Michael Bailey from
Northwestern university.